the First Amendment and free speech is
really important to me as a progressive
and it also should be really really
important to libertarian minded
individuals free speech and the First
Amendment should be really important to
the constitutional fetishists on the
right as i called them because again the
First Amendment is part of the
Constitution the Bill of Rights and it's
increasingly disturbing that the current
White House under President Donald Trump
has been systematically attacking the
institution of free speech and making us
question whether the First Amendment is
in danger in some way further because of
the attacks on fact as we've seen from
alternative facts and and so much else
of what's come out of the Trump
administration the opposition's use of
the First Amendment and free speech has
never been more important to defend
journalism to combat religious idealism
in government and Donald Trump's
positions and actions have been an
affront to many of these protections
that I thought were guaranteed by the
First Amendment this includes freedom of
speech freedom of the press and
separation of church and state let's put
up an image here for you from Donald
Trump I want to call your attention to
something we covered before the
inauguration of Trump where Donald Trump
tweeted about burning the American flag
saying nobody should be allowed to burn
the American flag if they do there must
be consequences perhaps loss of
citizenship or a year in jail this is an
issue the Supreme Court as I told you at
the time had already decided on in 1989
they decided about this that what Donald
Trump was suggesting would be a
violation of the First Amendment and by
the way the Supreme Court also decided
in 1958 that taking away someone's
citizenship as some kind of punishment
is unconstitutional under the Eighth
Amendment what do you think the chances
are that Trump had any idea that much of
what he was saying had already been
counteracted by the Supreme Court in in
indicating that it would violate the
Constitution we already know from
Trump's past defamation lawsuits that
he's prone to limiting people's speech
on legally questionable grounds in 2006
donald trump sued a journalist who said
Trump's not as rich as he tells people
Trump lost in court in 2012 Donald Trump
threatened to sue a journalist for a
column that called Donald Trump a clown
and pointed out that this Tampa
skyscraper Trump was going to build was
never built in 2013 and this one more of
our audience probably knows about trump
sued Bill Maher because Bill Maher made
a joke about Trump being the son of an
orangutan Trump ended up withdrawing
that lawsuit in 2015 Trump threatened to
sue a think tank because they ran ads
that criticized Donald Trump's political
positions on taxes and health care and
last year in 2016 after a las vegas
restaurant union handed out some
anti-trump flyers trump sued them for
trademark violations that lawsuit is
still pending so the attack from Trump
as a private citizen on people being
able to say what's on their mind has
been steady and concerning and during
his campaign we actually saw the
American Bar Association draft the
report saying that Trump is what they
call a quote libel bully and an abuser
of libel laws the Association decided
not to publish it because they were
actually afraid Trump would sue them for
libel for punishing it and during his
campaign Trump actually said he will try
to open up the libel laws against
journalists yet another way in which
freedom of the press would be stifled if
Trump had his way remember this I think
the media is among the most dishonest
groups of people I've ever met step sir
and believe me if I become president oh
do they have problems they're gonna have
such fun I'm going to open up our libel
laws so when they write purposely
negative and horrible and false articles
we can sue them and win lots of money
we're going to open up those libel laws
yeah and the key thing is the first
thing Trump says when they write
negative things the free speech and Free
Press provisions in the First Amendment
exist in large part to allow people to
openly and freely criticize the
government in its officials without fear
of reprisals Trump got a resounding
applause when he said that he would open
up the libel laws who even know average
American citizen even care about that no
they don't i don't know about care but
they don't even know what he's talking
about that of the reality and we know
how thin skinned and authoritarian
Donald Trump is his MO is antagonized
anyone who questions him until they back
down Kellyanne conned me I'm sorry
Kellyanne conway's Orwellian threat
Freudian slide their threat to limit the
presses communication with the White
House if they don't like their questions
is another example of this Chuck Todd
asked a totally legitimate question that
we've all been wondering about which is
why did Sean Spicer the press secretary
go out there and lie to everybody about
the attendance to Trump's inauguration
and Kellyanne convey Conway responded by
threatening to cut off nbc's access to
the president's staff take a look at
this we played this before just a
reminder did not answer the question why
did the president send out his press
secretary who's not just the
spokesperson for Donald Trump he could
be this also serves as the spokesperson
for all of America at time he speaks for
all of the country at time why put him
out there the for the very first time in
front of that podium to utter a provable
falsehood it's a small thing but the
first time he confronts the public it's
a falsehood Chuck and we're going to
keep referring to our press secretary in
those types of terms I think that we're
going to have to rethink our
relationship here the threat of Lou
access another way to stifle the free
speech of media outlets Donald Trump has
also shut down the white house comment
line a phone number that people could
call to leave a message for the white
house is being reported also that
signatures on petitions on the White
House website are not being counted
Trump is not allowing certain federal
agencies to communicate directly with
the public such as issuing news releases
or responding to questions and there are
legal experts arguing that all of this
violates The Whistleblower Protection
Enhancement Act of 2012 the whole point
of which was to ensure that agencies are
able to report waste to report fraud to
report abuse the Trump administration is
also going in the direction of
suppressing free speech with their anti
net neutrality efforts which directly
threaten free speech and equal access to
airwaves and media this applies to web
content publishers this also applies to
people just accessing web content I've
told you before Trump seems to have very
little clue what net neutrality is but
he's been against it for a while and we
see this through his appointment of a
GTI a former Verizon lawyer no less to
be FCC Chairman he's undone about 12
Obama era consumer advocacy policies and
proposals including the Obama
administration's net neutrality efforts
to classify Internet service as a public
utility that's hugely important in
preventing Internet service providers
from discriminating against Internet
traffic there's a whole host of ways
including trying to keep prison phone
rates down which Ajit Pai has pushed
back against the protections that the
Obama administration tried to put in
place and then lastly separation of
church and state of course there's
plenty of arguments that can be made
that Donald Trump's Muslim ban violates
the separation of church and state
clauses of the First Amendment which
we've already talked a lot about but
Donald Trump has also vowed to quote
totally destroy the Johnson Amendment
which prevents religious leaders from
campaigning for political candidates
this also would violate the separation
of church and state aspect of the First
Amendment because it would allow
religious organization to have political
activism functions and still get those
tax exemptions that they're only
supposed to have because they're not
doing politics the assault on the First
Amendment Pat are probably half due to
Trump being an authoritarian right
fundamentally and then another half due
to just Trump ignorance about basic
civics and how government is supposed to
work and I mean really Trump's
constitutional issues expand far outside
of the First Amendment you really
doesn't have much respect for the
separation of powers remember even just
this week he attacked that Justice who
struck down his travel and Refugee band
yeah calling him a so-called judge and
then there's an argument to be made that
he's in violation of the emoluments
clause by accepting gifts from foreign
dignitaries but I think the first
amendment is probably most dear to
Americans heart well as progressives the
First Amendment is one of the few things
that we will have during the
administration with the Trump White
House and a Republican House in a
Republican Senate but you're right in
the irony of it it's sort of a sick and
disgusting irony is that the guy from
the party which supposedly Revere's the
Constitution like a religious document
is the guy who might be in violation of
the Constitution in multiple places and
I call it an irony sort of to laugh
instead of cry I guess but we have to
activate around these issues of speech
because the suppression is coming fast
and furious from the Trump
administration